video of nickels being beaten has been
shown all over social media it's been
shown right here on our newscast and it
can be traumatic to watch and a weight
on our mental health Dr Sheldon Jacobs
is a licensed therapist he says the body
our bodies they respond to trauma in
different ways so it's important to
recognize your triggers
it's very important that you know
yourself as well and if you think that
it's going to be you know something
that's going to be tough for you to
watch and and to to to manage then maybe
maybe you should not watch the video
Dr Jacobs recommends dealing with trauma
in positive ways and trying to use
coping mechanisms